i'm from flint
i was born there and raised um
i had a great father he was a good
hustler i had a mother though who
was unlike all mothers she was kind of
like a monster
for some reason she hated me and my
brother
um when i was 13 she got out of prison
and introduced me to heroin but i
introduced her to rock so i guess fair
exchange no robbery
um but she introduced me to heroin so
she could
use me on the streets working the
streets for her
um i never wanted her to love me
i just wanted her to like me to be nice
to me you know because she was my mother
and um i did it for a while then my dad
got out of prison
and made me kick cowan you know he asked
me to
give him another chance to be my father
and i looked at him i said you're always
going to be my
dad you know what give you another
chance you're my dad
and after i said that he made me kick i
didn't know what i was getting into but
i stayed clean for three years before i
came out to cali
and um came out here for a little while
i relapsed your mom was basically your
pimp
yeah oh yeah she was my pimp she i lost
my virginity to a slumlord
for 500 and look what she did to me she
this was my first date ever lost my
virginity
she got paid 500. you're how old 13.
and when i came out from doing it with
him
my mother was gone and i'm like what the
[ __ ] and then he got all nervous he was
like oh you got to leave
because he was a sexual predator he
couldn't have
children under 18 in his house without
their parents
so he put me out in midwinter in the
snow talking i had to take the bus home
and two days later my mother comes home
now i'm sick because i'm struggling on
heroin
she comes home with this guy who is like
400 pounds covered in hair
disgusting and she says if you want to
get well
you'll turn this date with this dude and
when he went to pay her
i was like well if you're going to pay
her then she can suck your dick because
i'm not
you know i'm not going through that
again getting ripped off so
i kind of got hit real quick you know
and um
so that's how i grew up with my mother
but i only went through it for like a
couple years because my dad got out when
i was 15
and made me kick caroline i didn't want
to but
he made me but once i was clean i was
cool
and then i came out to cali and relapsed
and was in the streets again doing my
thing working for escort services
i did a lot of [ __ ] out here i made a
lot of money
and um i've been out here ever since
you're not old
i'm 45 no but when you moved to
california i was 17.
it was like a month before my 18th
birthday and um
you worked as an escort yeah i worked
i worked escort services and made like
bad money mad money and uh
what was it i used to get their calls
like
i would get um calls they were really
good and i would give them my number
you're not supposed to do that
so i made me a black book so i didn't
have because the escort service charged
you like 40
out of your money so i was like [ __ ]
that
i'm not going to get what 40 almost half
so i started making me a black book and
pulling their
their calls so i had my own like
basically my own service going on
i did that for a while and uh
came downtown that's where it was like
drug city back then
i mean it was real cheap had fun down
here did a lot of [ __ ]
hung out with the homies and
okay basically later on i my homeboy
made me realize that i had a
good knack for selling drugs now see
i've been a hoe the whole time i was out
here
in the streets i've had a lot of bad
experiences i've had guns pulled on me
um got in the cars he goes the dude goes
parks and then
another guy pops out off the back you
know and then he takes his money back
i've had
like a lot of bad experiences out here
working the streets
but i mean come on it comes with the
territory
and then when my homeboy introduced me
and showed me that i had um i was good
at selling dope
i didn't because i did it all my life i
didn't know it was that good i made mad
money
like major money and when he introduced
me that he took me off the streets
i haven't hold since then it won't
because i got too much hustle too much
game
he showed me that uh there was more to
life than just hone
you know so it's been like
five years i haven't turned a trick
do other kinds of hustling now you know
whatever i need to do i'll do it
i won't go back to that because i hated
that anyways
it was easy money but it made me feel
like
not human basically i hated it
and um do you think all girls that work
as prostitutes have that experience
whether they admit it or not some girls
like it
some girls actually like doing it like
really
there is nothing cool to me about it i
don't want to be with somebody that i
don't like that makes my skin crawl
you know even if it was for a lot of
money
but i did it because of my addiction
but when my homie showed me that i had
more hustle than just that
it was cool he introduced me to a whole
another lifestyle
and um i made a lot of money with him
and we kind of like fell out i ended up
pregnant
okay let me tell you about my first son
i ended up pregnant 34 i waited for my
child for like
34 years when i thought i was pregnant i
kicked everything cold turkey
because i wanted to hold my baby more
than i wanted to get high
it was my first child waited for a long
time for him
i got clean brought him home from the
hospital had him for a year
and i was selling dope back then but my
only mistake was
i was running i was on the run on parole
i never checked in
so i had a parole warrant so when they
finally caught up to me
he was like almost a year old and it was
very hard
like i got um taken to jail
got eight months flat for a violation
and he was like 11 months old so when i
got out he was two
and um i didn't think he was gonna
remember me but he remembered me
you know he was so happy to see me and
then um
the visit ended
it was really hard because he threw a
fit he kept saying
mommy sorry may be good maybe good like
he thought he had done something wrong
and i didn't know how to explain to a
two-year-old that it's not his fault
that you know i'll see you next week
everything's gonna be okay they don't
understand they think
they did something wrong so
it was like the little boy that i waited
all that time before i had to let go
or i had to put them through this [ __ ]
like once a week
children's services don't even realize
how bad children are affected by
their um whatever they call it
reunification thing
how do you explain to a two-year-old
that you know
he he hasn't done nothing wrong it's
just he has to go back to these people
he don't know
and mommy you see him next week he don't
understand that
he thinks he did something wrong
so he lives in diamond bar he has a good
mother
so i gave up my custody of him instead
of putting him through that
once a week and making him think
he did something wrong
i mean i wanted him back for me but
i would be being selfish to him
by putting him through all that [ __ ]
because i know how it is when you think
that it's your fault so um
i let my son go
that's been 11 years ago anyways
back to ford um
anyways i was with my homie we kind of
fell out
i thought i was pregnant didn't know it
i was seven months pregnant
didn't know it didn't show i thought i
was pregnant when um
my daughter kicked and uh
a week later i went to um
premature labor i was like seven months
a week
pregnant and um we both almost died
because i'm rh negative
and my blood combats her like she's an
infection and tries to get rid of her i
have to have a shot to carry her full
term
um she was born but she was fully
developed
and thank god she was in the neonatal
intensive care unit for like
two months it was horrible and that's
how i [ __ ] up
my my homie up
every every work that i got from him i'd
say outside the hospital
and just smoke it all up you know i
wasn't even trying to serve sell hustle
nothing
because i was [ __ ] up in my head it's
like how could i be pregnant
all this time and not know it and uh
anyways i went to court with her
and come to find out that she ends up
in the same foster home my son got
adopted in
and there's a note with the caseworkers
saying that um
the um foster mother wants to adopt skye
so she can keep jaylon and skye together
since their blood
so then i realized i kind of thought
about it i realized she was never meant
for me
she was meant for jaylon you know to
keep
brother and sister together so i went
ahead and signed the papers and let her
be with her brother
but at least now i know because i always
thought like i wonder if he knows he's
adopted you know
does he know that he's a mother out here
but now i know he does because
he knows that that foster baby is his
real sister
so he's gotten always adopted so i let
i let her have i have them
i signed custody over because i was in
no position
to take her or try to raise her
and jaylon deserves some kind of blood
in his life
you know so she wanted to keep them
together so i went ahead and
signed my custody off um
i've done a lot of [ __ ] out here i've
seen a lot of [ __ ]
seen murders all kinds of [ __ ]
[ __ ] people you want to talk about you
know but i won't talk about
i've seen a lot of [ __ ] done a lot of
[ __ ]
you've been down here how many years um
over 20 years
like almost 30 years i came out here
when i was 17.
yeah cause i got a [ __ ] up family
i mean my mother the only good person in
my whole family was my father
he's a good man tell me where your dad
um
he was a junkie um and a hustler
you know he hustled he hustled hard but
he loved his family
he loved his kids he loved his family
and he took care of us the best he could
and even when we got older he still took
care of us
like um that's what he's in jail now for
over his family um
he's doing life in mexico because he got
kicked out of the united states because
i guess he's been to prison so many
times
and um he's got life i haven't seen him
like 20 years
yeah i miss my dad
and that's why i do this because it
numbs me
it does it keeps me known
a lot of things in life don't make me
cry but my children
make me cry
um hopefully i see them one day again
on good note you know i don't want to
interrupt their lives
or put them off track i just want what's
best for them as any mother would
that's why i can't understand how my
mother was like she was
she had to really hate us
to do what she did but she was an addict
as well though
yeah but so am i i wouldn't sell my
child
i wouldn't even get high with my child
so
i don't understand she got murdered in
2012
which wasn't surprising and uh when i
was told
by my ex um he said your mom got
murdered she's dead
and i i looked at him i was just like ah
i felt relieved and i felt like i was a
bad person because i didn't feel sad or
i didn't feel
yeah i didn't feel sad i just felt
relieved like i could breathe
you know like the monster is gone
and then i was like damn am i [ __ ] up
for feeling like that you know
kind of child feel like that about their
own mother but she was never a mother to
me
so um it is what it is
she was real scandalous dude she did
some scandalous [ __ ]
to me all my life but um it finally
caught up to her
and you know it was crazy it's because i
didn't even realize this even when
i found out she was murdered and she
came out here for a visit
and she was smoking her tweak was she
thought she was gonna be murdered
like she would slide off the couch to
take a hit slide off the couch get all
paranoid
tell us how to get down that somebody's
gonna shoot the windows
and i'd be so embarrassed i'd be like
get off the floor [ __ ] you're
embarrassing me get up
or she'll go in the hallway in between
the walls and like crouch down
i'm like what did this [ __ ] she had to
do some grimy
slimy [ __ ] for her tweet to be thinking
that she's gonna get murdered
right now ten years later she gets
murdered
and i didn't even trip on it until it
was me and my ex sitting there
and i was like we're talking about her
and i was humble
am i a bad person about feeling like the
way i felt he was like nah
and then we said something about her
tweet i said do you realize what her
tweak was
that she was going to be murdered ain't
that something like is it a coincidence
or what
you know like she knew she had some [ __ ]
coming
because all the [ __ ] she did all her
life
i guess grimy people know
what's your what's your drug today
uh-huh what do you smoke crack of course
i smoke crack but i i my first drug of
choice is heroin
she introduced me to the love of my life
yes she did
um yeah heroin does everyone still work
for you
you just you're just making yourself
well uh
a lot of times majority of the time i
just get well i don't get high
it's hard for me to get high it's like i
use so much
and then i don't have no veins there's
nowhere to shoot
so most time i'm just getting well i
don't even get high no more
where do you stay now in the streets i'm
still homeless
yeah in the streets i've been with my
dude for like five years now
we've been going through some tough [ __ ]
lately
because i feel like he cheats on me
maybe that's because
i don't know i really feel like that
like because he shows signs of [ __ ]
you know you know your dude's behavior
when something's off you know it
you know you know when he does something
a certain way you know what time it is
you're not stupid you know
women can sense that yeah like totally
and he thinks i'm an idiot dude
and i'm like you're going to end up
[ __ ] off a good thing because i think
i'm a good woman i'm liking if they're
worth it [ __ ] it
yeah we've been going through some hard
times lately
but i'm getting tired you think you'll
ever
get clean me i want to
yeah i want to but right now at this
point no
until i deal with my what they call it
[ __ ]
yeah that's really the core of it all
isn't it yeah until i deal with
my emotions whatever yeah i'm again
cuz i'm gonna try to stay numb
nobody wants to think about [ __ ]
or deal with it so i run for my past
and until i can learn to deal with it
i'll be running
i'll be high be smoking
be hustling i guess until something
better comes along
[Music]
and i don't know what that is did you
have dreams when you were a young girl
of doing something with your life
you know i wanted to be a
art dealer and live in new york because
i like art
i like beautiful things
yeah but then i went out the door
when i realized my parents got high i
mean my brother used to peek
through the registers and watch them get
high you know it was
kids are really smart they're really
nosy you know
parents don't even know what that their
kids know
exactly what's going on you know when
they do some
dirty [ __ ] or got some deals the kids
know everything
they don't do what the parents say they
do what the parents do yeah that's crazy
kids are very smart so when i'm around
kids i'm like go
play go outside i don't even want them
in how in the house because i know how i
was when i was a kid
i knew my mother and my dad kept their
needles in the towels
i knew when the their friends came over
and went in the bedroom
i said watch they're going to come boil
water because they're going to fix
i was like eight years old who does that
they don't know what time it is
they're about to get high watch dad's
gonna come out loaded
and they do it's like kids are really
smart dude
and i know that because i was a kid and
i knew i knew what time it was
yeah parents think they're hiding [ __ ]
from their kids but they're really not
and kids are like sponges they soak up
everything and want to do what their
parents do
yeah sure do
so what are you afraid of no what am i
afraid of
what am i afraid of never seeing my kids
besides that nothing i'm not i don't
fear death
everybody i mean we live to die
you know everybody dies at one point um
i've od so many times it's like i'm just
thankful i
i able to wake up you know and it's not
really because of me it's because the
person i'm with
affecting them how scared they are their
look when i come to
um i don't know i don't
fear a lot of things in life like what
about fentanyl venom
if you're playing around with heroin is
that null um i'm cautious
you know i know better i know i got
testers i know how to test it
i only deal with certain people i don't
just put anything in my arm
you know i don't just shoot anything
now i have ran into some fentanyl and
that's how i ended up odin a couple
times
but by the grace of god i'm still here
um it didn't really scare me it shocked
me
and it showed me that i was being sloppy
with
how i was doing my drugs you know i
wasn't doing it like i should have been
like testing the dope especially if it's
dope i'd never done before i should have
tested it
um and it's always good to do
less than too much you know i'd rather
do a little bit
and be able to do more than do too much
and not be able to come back
and a lot of people don't understand
they're greeting they want to do a big
shot
no dude if you've never done that before
do a little bit you it's cool you always
can do more
it's not like there's not tomorrow you
know
but if you do too much it's a wrap you
can't do
less can't take it back and
you're gone so what do you think the the
core is of
self-destructive behavior i mean like
the story you told earlier about your
two-year-old son thinking he did
something wrong
yeah kind of shows a lot of what what
the thinking is
among many humans right yeah they think
itself
yeah we hate ourselves and we need to be
yeah because i didn't i treat it
accordingly yeah it blew me away when he
was like
please i'm sorry i'll be good like don't
make me go
i just stood there i was like blown away
i didn't know what to say what do you
say to a two-year-old but but
your behavior do you think maybe the way
your mom treated you the way
your childhood was kind of set you on
this path
um i'm a survivor from her
i like yeah definitely set me on this
path
you've been doing it so long maybe you
can't even see outside of outside the
box
outside the box yeah yeah but um
i know i'm a junkie because of her and
that's my first love
my first hate my first love but as an
outsider looking at your
listening to your story if you grew up
in a family
maybe like mine or or a more i'd be more
aware of it
yeah it's it's not likely that you have
taken this path
yeah i know i wouldn't know and it's
like
it's tragic because you didn't have any
choice in the matter no i didn't
when um you can't pick your parents no
and some parents aren't any good rotten
to the core
some people shouldn't even have kids
like she should've never had kids
i don't know what her trip was dude she
wasn't a nice person
she was always about herself herself you
know if you could have changed one
part of your i would change my mother
change your mother
i would have changed i would have asked
for a new mother
that might have changed a lot for you it
would i probably wouldn't be here you'd
be in new york you know
yeah i'd be in new york or building some
kind of
building some kind of designing some
kind of building yeah out of an
architect
it undermines your childhood like that
undermines your ability to just
sink your teeth and feed into something
and make something happen for yourself
doesn't it yeah because that was a dream
and then drugs become part of the issue
and then it then all drugs become
the only issue but i don't see drugs is
the problem i see mental health is the
problem
yeah growing up dealing with yeah having
a childhood like that
makes you want to use the drug and then
the drug becomes an addiction and then
you're out of control
but the problem is not the drug the
problem is the mindset that you had
from having a mom that tipped you out
and trying to numb and not think about
the [ __ ] you're doing because your
mother
yeah no you're absolutely right
absolutely right we just use drugs to
numb
our feelings and yeah it's all about me
very our emotions yeah it's all mental
health i think
yep what's your biggest regret
in your life my biggest regret
um indulging with my mother
but you were young yeah i know but still
i i knew enough
maybe kids are not stupid i knew enough
but i it was because i never wanted her
to love me i just wanted her to be nice
i shouldn't care about that because i
would have never got high with her
and she was nice to me when we were
getting high and i was making money
so
yeah what's the most important thing
you've learned in your life
most important thing family
i do realize that living life
is all surrounded around family like i
look at these families who
like the aunts and uncles they get
together they go to their nephew's
graduation
it's all about family you know you're
helping your family
either your nephew to get get a job send
them to college
it's centered around family
that's what life's about
that's what makes it happy dude
i mean yeah a career or a job but who's
who's the support in the background
it's family you know your sister your
brother your dad
your mother your aunt whoever it's all
centered around
family being family oriented you know
having your own family that's what i
realized life is about
it seems like it's the underlying
stabilizing force in everyone's life of
life yeah
because if you didn't have it you'll
fall into all the without that
foundation how can you build
you know that's your foundation
yeah but that's what i realized i was
actually i was standing
and watching um the little girl take
pictures of her parents
and then it was like the aunt the uncle
in the background
like just proud watching her and i'm
like that's what
happiness is surrounded by it's family
you know that's what we live life for
yeah i guess they were on vacation or
something they were taking pictures of
everything
but it's family that's
i don't know how to explain it but i
know that's the foundation of life
and that's what you build on so you have
your own one day you know you got your
parents
your brothers your sisters and then one
day you have your own family
you know your own kids and then your
sisters and brothers become the aunts
and uncles that you used to have
you know so
maybe
yeah but until then i'm gonna stay high
all right whisper thank you so much for
coming in again
yes thank you
you